as the establishment media's credibility
on
every single topic from kovid to war to
hunter biden's laptop that was another
great one that just popped up as it
collapses i'm so honored to be joined by
one of the great journalists around
today one of the few greats a woman who
needs no introduction megan kelly you
know her well you know her from all over
the place you know from the megan kelly
show she's on sirius she's on everywhere
and she's got a huge new interview
coming up with robert f kennedy jr megan
thank you for being on the show
hi my pleasure thank you for the kind
words so i am
eagerly awaiting this this hours long
what was it three hour long interview or
something with robert kennedy four hours
longest longest i've ever done so we
split it into two shows i cannot wait
i've seen the teasers the teasers have
done their job they've gotten me very
excited i want to get to some other news
of the day too but i'm i'm really
interested in this vaccine issue and
frankly specifically robert f kennedy i
was raised to believe vaccines of all
types are totally fine totally safe
anyone who has any questions about them
are completely insane i specifically
thought robert f kennedy jr like his
entire family was completely insane and
not worth talking to and not worth
reading and then
kovit happened and then we were lied to
by the cdc we were lied to by dr fauci
especially at the daily wire we have a
three-part series right now fauci
unmasked on his lies and incompetence
the whole thing collapsed now pfizer is
telling us that the 100 effective and
safe vaccines we now need a fourth shot
we need another booster so
i take another look at this robert f
kennedy jr he seems to have some
worthwhile things to say
you know he's been completely silenced i
mean completely silenced by the
mainstream media but not even just the
mainstream michael like even people in
conservative media are too afraid to
talk to rfk jr and it's a shame because
he's incredibly brilliant he's devoted
his life to fighting environmental
toxins and pollutants and things that
none of us wants in our waters where our
kids swim or our air that we all breathe
and the thing that's gotten him in
trouble is his conclusions on vaccines
they're his opinions based on what he
says are facts but they're so
controversial so says the media that
he's a man who may not be heard from you
know he's in the malone mccullough group
but he was there before they were part
of the disinformation dozen where we had
our white house our government trying to
silence speech which is unlawful
and
it's it's unfortunate on a number of
levels number one even if what he's
saying is wrong why can't we debate it
and number two what if he's right and we
really need somebody with the courage to
say it and number three
robert f kennedy jr has one of the most
fascinating life stories and family
history of any living human
and why we would just throw him away
because we may have questions about his
vaccine stance and forget to ask him
about his life history and what it was
like growing up the son of rfk the
nephew of jfk and so on
is beyond me it's so myopic it's so
stupid and such a such an example of
just
how partisan we are right now and how
holier than thou we are about he who
dispenses misinformation versus me who
will give you all the correct
information oh really really like the
new york post who got you know they were
disinformation until the new york times
now jumped on board with the hunter
biden thing and now we can talk about it
right well this is what's really opened
my eyes to this is
you my friend andrew clavin mentions
this all the time he says you open up
the newspaper and you read an article
about syria and you don't know anything
about syria so you assume it's true then
you turn to an article about crime and
you don't know anything about crime so
you assume it's true then you opened up
to an article about the yankees and you
do know about the yankees and you can
see that what the paper is telling you
is false
but then you move on to the next topic
you don't know that you believe them too
and there is now
such uh a dearth of respect for these
outlets we have such little trust in
these outlets especially after
the the new york times and and big tech
and the rest of the establishment
basically rigged the 2020 election by
suppressing a story that they now admit
was true and significant so you look at
someone like rfk junior
as you mentioned he's a kennedy it's so
easy for kennedy's to get on tv to get
on platforms i think they they give you
a tv interview at your third birthday if
you're a candidate
for some reason rfk junior has been
silenced you compare them to dr
mccullough dr malone
actually it's even worse dr mccullough
and dr malone occasionally can get out
there but it's it seems to have been
much harder for rfk i mean one of his
complaints to me in the interview was
that other than tucker giving him one
interview um no one would book him that
even rogan
he said was too afraid to book him
and to me that's really unfortunate
because there's a way of doing an
interview with a guy like rfk jr that
you know should pass anyone's basic
tests of fairness right like with all
due respect to joe rogan and i
appreciate what he does
um i he doesn't fact check you know
that's not really what he does i'm a
journalist so i will fact check you know
i'm sort of in a different business and
it's really not that hard you know i
mean a lot of the stuff is unknowable
like you can't
give the audience a definitive
pronouncement on some of these claims
but it's really not that hard just do a
little homework figure out what the
other side sort of the mainstream
medical community is saying ask the
guest about it or add context to what he
said after the fact and then the
audience gets to decide i don't need to
be a scientific expert expert on
vaccines on toxins all i need to do is
make sure that i have both sides fairly
represented and the audience is
clued in on where the disputes are and
then they can make up their own minds
why is that not allowed when it comes to
rfk's opinions because we're talking
about children because we're talking
about vaccines because we're talking
about maybe dissuading parents from
getting vaccines that we don't want um
you know for diseases that we don't want
resuming in our society
well that's no
reason to completely silence the guy
because
right now his book is flying off the
shelves people want to hear from him for
the reasons you just said we just lived
through a covet epidemic in which half
of the country plus
lost all faith in our public health
agencies and so they're seeking out
people who have been silenced who have
been critical of these industries and
agencies before this point and the
answer to that is not to just try to
stifle try to shut up join the
censorship crowd the answer is to talk
to them and see if their ideas hold up
so
now you do a great job at presenting
these ideas of interrogating rfk but
i've got to turn it on you did he
convince you
he gave me some pause on the childhood
vaccines he did he did i'm not gonna lie
i um i had all my kids and i have three
of them vaccinated with all the regular
schedule of vaccines um and they're fine
thank god but
rfk is really smart and has been living
this topic for a long long time and i
think he raises some good points about
the way this was approached and just the
for all along sort of the shutdown to
any suggestion that the vaccines might
have something to do with forget autism
for right now because that's so
controversial yeah but some of the
issues we're seeing in children whether
it's adhd or ticks
or um just certain developmental
disorders because
some of the things that are in vaccines
are unquestionably environmental toxins
you know i mean for a while there was
mercury in the vaccines it's been taken
out of all but the flu vaccine now
um
some of them have aluminum
he raises questions about whether we
should be
subjecting kids to a vaccine schedule
where they're getting some aluminum i
mean you can get that in your deodorant
so that's the other side saying you get
aluminum whether you want it or not as a
human right um and then also some
mercury if you take the flu vaccine so
he was raising questions like that and
you know we we have the other side i
went
if you look at the industry
a lot of these doctors out there are
totally owned by anthony fauci by the
cdc by big pharma like you can't put
them on television you can't say well
this person says rfk jr is wrong because
that other person is bought and paid for
by the groups he's criticizing so we
tried to find a couple doctors that
we've trusted on our show in the past
couple of years who are not like that
and we went to them and said
what should we know about this claim
what what does our audience need to know
about like
mercury in the vaccines or aluminum and
so on and so we've we've done all that
for the audience we've kind of done the
heavy lifting so that they can walk
through the journey with us but even our
experts were saying
there's there's there's cause for
concern or skepticism but not cynicism
when it comes to the childhood vaccines
and so
it's a worthy discussion to have that's
where i landed i i still would have my
kids vaccinated the way i did
um i'm not sure i'd be doing the flu
vaccine every year um
but that's my own conclusion and so you
know people have to watch it and figure
it out for themselves i love that
distinction skepticism not cynicism
because we're not saying that there is
some cabal of reptilian monsters who
have colluded in a cave somewhere to
poison the entire world that's not
exactly the claim is just that science
is complicated that politics is
complicated that people have vested
interests in pushing certain treatments
i've talked to doctors
all over the country both coasts who are
very well respected lots of great
degrees and i asked them specifically
about the covid vaccine i say look i'm a
healthy young person no underlying
health conditions as far as i can tell
i'm not
at risk or immunocompromised or whatever
the terms are should i get the vaccine
and the doctors have told me pharmacists
have told me and doctors cardiologists
other people have said
no if i were you i wouldn't do it your
risk of covid is just not great enough
to justify taking this experimental drug
i said oh great so are you going to say
that publicly they say no i could lose
my license well that right seems to
raise a lot of questions
that's right and think about like rfk jr
has been prior to getting involved in
the vaccine issue
one of the most respected environmental
lawyers in the united states i mean he
he's helped clean up the hudson river
which i used to swim in as a kid i could
have been at nasa michael i could have
been a michael knowles i could have been
a whiz kid but no i swam in the hudson
as a child and i wound up me um but
anyway
he's he's been instrumental in cleaning
up problems like that he cares about the
air we breathe and the water we swim in
and so on and so
in any sane world we'd be looking to him
for more information like what toxins
should we be concerned with you know do
we all the stuff they talk about and
like you know monsanto he sued monsanto
and was told in the trial no no no
everything they use is is not a toxin
it's nothing to be worried about and
then he wins he wins these cases and you
know you can say he's a nutcase all you
want but he's winning court victory
after victory it's just the media has
done such a good job of painting him as
a loon um that he gets discredited and i
have to tell you
even you know i travel now more in
conservative circles just given all my
years at fox and you know now i'm i'm
on siriusxm
um
even some of our conservative brethren
in the media are too afraid to air clips
of this interview michael yeah they're
afraid they're afraid of being censored
they're afraid of being called anti-vaxx
it's like would you grow a pair just
like so what so what if there's blow
back so like be a man or a woman stand
up take your licks don't be part of the
censorship brigade because you're part
of the problem right it's like that word
racist i remember when i was a student
ann coulter came to college and she gave
a lecture and she said when a leftist
calls you a racist you know you've won
the argument because they don't have any
argument left so they just throw this
word at you it's the worst thing you can
be called in america i think it's the
same with anti-vaxx it's it's one of
these labels they throw on you it has no
argument that it goes along with it it
doesn't matter what you've said
you know the other one and i want to get
to this also with you because you're so
good at cutting through the bs on on all
sides you say you move now more in
conservative circles but you're pretty
good at cutting through the bs on both
sides so this this other term now that's
thrown around is you're you're pro putin
you're a putin stooge if just the other
day mitt romney
accused tulsi gabbard a democrat former
member of congress
american service member of being a
traitor to her country of being a stooge
for putin because
she acknowledged facts about american
programs with ukrainian bio laboratories
that are now even acknowledged by the
state department
you know what's happening right now with
the russia story in the ukraine story is
deeply disturbing to me and you're right
it's not unlike the conversation we're
having on vaccines
in the mainstream they want you to
believe there is one truth period and
there will be no doubting that
quote-unquote truth well we went along
with that on the iraq war a lot of us
right in covering that and the people
who voted for it and you would think
that we had learned
maybe we should ask more questions maybe
blind patriotism or you know
backing of the u.s president in his
decision isn't always the patriotic
thing to do right the best thing for the
country the best thing for american
service personnel or us
um there's nothing wrong with asking
questions and the people who want to
silence that are the ones we should be
suspicious of you know i as you know i
had you on my show not long ago you were
more skeptical about what's happening uh
in ukraine and you know about our
involvement i've had more neocon types
on i've had um lots of people who like
rodriguez on who was very anti any us
involvement very skeptical about the
claims that are being made that to me is
the answer you know i
i listen to tucker he's got a very
different message and tulsi does too
than some of my friends who do like the
commentary podcast who probably call
themselves neocons john fedoras and noah
rothman and so on i like that michael i
i like hearing
both sides and then i will decide i will
decide after hearing the information and
the opinions from both sides what i
believe because there isn't necessarily
in a case like this
one truth right
it's like you have to keep listening to
people you trust who can have a
divergence of opinion and walk away a
bit smarter and if you're a bit smarter
you'll probably be a little less certain
and that's okay
what you're describing is something so
foreign megan today and that would be
journalism it would be uh reporting
there was a tv journalist who came on
i'll
leave her name list to be polite but she
came on to debunk tulsi gabbard's
comments and i suppose tucker's comments
too maybe my comments and you know the
handful of others who were talking about
those bio labs
she she debunked the the arguments by
reading verbatim from talking points
given to her by the pentagon now i i
don't begrudge the pentagon for trying
to get their talking points out there
that is not journalism when you are
reading talking points handed to you by
the government you you have to
interrogate that interrogate the other
people and try to get to what the what
the actual truth of the matter is that's
like trying to debunk a claim that you
know dr malone is making with a
statement from the cdc we no longer
trust trust them we no longer trust the
cdc we don't trust anthony fauci we
don't trust uh rochelle wolenski and for
very good reason you know they went into
just to back up uh a week ago i watched
that show that movie contagion with my
kids for the first time with gwene
paltrow and uh matt damon really good
how did you know i showed it to them at
the beginning of the pandemic i watched
it my my wife and i sat down at the
probably three weeks into kovid we sat
down and just happened to watch that
movie we said are are we living in a
simulation right now are we living in
netflix
it's amazing right it's amazing and they
worked apparently with the cdc and our
health officials
in doing that movie to predict what
would likely happen and you know hashtag
nailed it
so it was all very fascinating but that
movie presumed a level of trust in our
public health agencies that no longer
exists and when we entered this pandemic
it did
it didn't have to be sacrificed as it
was we what we saw was hyper
partisanship active lying hiding of
information silencing of questioning
voices
and in that movie they have a jude law
character who's more questioning who's
poking holes but of course they paint
him as a complete kook right as anthony
fauci has tried to do now to anybody who
questions his you know the
the the origins of kovid as possibly
coming from a lab how do we've seen
the papers in which he said they need to
be discredited he and and collins used
to run the nih so we've seen their
disinformation campaign and now we have
a much better window into who they are
and it's been a travesty it's been a
travesty because it would have been nice
not just to trust them when they're not
trustworthy but to have actual
trustworthy institutions and what rfk jr
has been saying all along is
they're not
i'm telling you as someone who's
litigated against them for years they
weren't just not trustworthy starting at
the beginning of the pandemic they've
been not trustworthy for a long long
time and let me explain to you why let
me tell you about anthony fauci in what
drives him and how much money the cdc
and the fda in particular get from
big pharma and who they're actually
loyal to i didn't understand all that i
didn't know going into the pandemic how
much money the fda gets from big pharma
how tied they are how tied even the nih
is to big pharma in various ways i i
learned all of that in preparation for
this interview and over the past two
years people should know and then they
can make up their own minds about these
sweeping they don't have anything
anything to do with autism they don't
have anything to do with any childhood
allergies make up your own mind don't do
not put your trust in anthony fauci
because he doesn't deserve it ironically
when when dr fauci and his minions when
they
insist on a narrative and they are 100
confident of it
there is nothing that makes me more
skeptical of whatever the collective
they could tell me the sky is blue they
could tell me that sugar is sweet and
yet if it's them telling me at this
point they've so squandered their
credibility
i'm going to have questions
i feel the same i remember um and back
to the other you know discussion on
russia ukraine feeling the same like i
obviously zelinski is putting out
information that is in part propaganda
for totally understandable reasons i
know that but you have to be skeptical
right because he wants us to get
involved but he's not worried about
what's best for america he's worried
about what's best for him and ukraine
okay
i get it but that doesn't mean we have
to go along and do whatever he says
and putin obviously is a propaganda
machine so i mean people already know to
be skeptical there but in that story
there was a there was a story about one
guy
sort of a nerdy guy michael who worked
uh for the eu
and uh sort of them as a governing body
and he'd been kicking the tires and he'd
been walking around to all the european
partners for a while now saying you know
here's here are some sanctions that
might work and might actually make some
sense nobody wanted to do anything
and he was this tireless nerdy worker
bee who eventually i guess really played
an instrumental instrumental part in
getting them to agree as a as a cohesive
unit to do more you know germany to
build up its military and so on i'm like
okay i want to hear from him yeah i'd
listen to him
i don't want to hear from jake sullivan
i don't want to hear from biden
certainly no one here from kamala harris
she knows nothing i think my
eight-year-old could educate me better
on ukraine i think you're right
right and same about fauci wallenski do
you see him now saber-rattling about
another variant it's like of course no
one is listening to you
no one cares only the far left loons are
still paying any attention you've lost
your 15 minutes they're over you need an
exit stage left and what is he doing
right now he wants billions of dollars
from the federal government for his next
act which is going to be to develop more
vaccines uh so he can get rich i guess
in his
post-governmental life i know i know
i've got to let you go but i i do need
to hear your thoughts on this so fauci
he had gone into witness protection i
think he was shoved in a bunker by
democrats who saw what he was doing to
their poll numbers in an election year
but but you're right they're still
saber-rattling about this biden is
vowing to veto any attempt to remove the
national emergency authorization for
covid you're hearing about more vaccines
we need another totally safe and
effective booster we're going to be on
our 20th booster pretty soon you're
you're hearing more talks about a new
variant and a sub variant
even if the covid issue is being
suppressed right now very likely for
political reasons
do you think
that anthony fauci is going to get
another act do you think even more
broadly that they're going to try to
drag covet out or have we finally beaten
this thing
i don't think they can and it's not
because of anything to do with the
science or you know it has to do with
the fact that the political realities
are what made them pull up the stops on
their battle on this and they haven't
changed and they're not going to change
you know if we get some variant michael
that's absolutely devastating and looks
more like the virus we saw in contagion
right like it was like 30 death rate
right um who knows right but if if we
just get another variant like another
delta another omicron you know we kind
of figured out kovan now it's it is
potentially very deadly for the elderly
for those who are obese who have you
know one of these other comorbidities
but for the vast majority of us it's
nothing um so if it's something like
that no no one's gonna do this the
political will is not there for another
round of restrictions even in
the deep blue cities that's where i've
been living and all my friends are in
new york i just left new york city i'm
lifelong new york state or now i'm in
connecticut blue blue blue blue there's
a reason they took down the restrictions
and it wasn't because the democrat
governors were like i see the light they
are worried about their own backsides
yeah they they're going to get tossed
out of office it was going to be a
bloodbath come november they know that
it's not going to change so you know
unless we get some new
virus or some completely catastrophic
version of this virus which is not how
viruses go they don't go from like
pretty bad to like less bad to
absolutely nothing to the worst ever
that would have to be a new one it's not
gonna happen it's uh that is a really a
note of hope and i think you're right i
think it's all about the politics i
think people have had their eyes opened
they they're not going to be they're
going to believe their own lying eyes
rather than what they're hearing from dr
fauci when megan can we hear this
interview with rfk jr
so we split it into two parts monday's
part one tuesday is part two and i'll
tell you what monday is sort of all the
vaccines and fouchy and stuff like that
and part two is more of his family uh
discussion and and he goes deep on
cheryl hines his wife and how the she's
gotten so much blowback on
his comments like the people in
hollywood trying to hold her accountable
for his positions
fascinating and really heartfelt
discussion with him about that and his
feelings and that statement she issued
sort of condemning his comments at the
freedom rally where he made a comment
about how even anne frank could run and
hide anyway we go there and we go into
who he believes assassinated his father
his uncle
what he thinks about the medical
industrial complex and the intelligence
complex
running our country and
what we need to be concerned about uh
but yeah part one starts monday and
that's in depth on vaccines fauchi and
public health i cannot wait to listen
you can go get it at the megan kelly
show listen on sirius go to megan's
youtube channel you know where to find i
don't need to tell you where to find
megan callie megan thank you so much for
being here
thanks michael all the best
[Music]
[Music]
you